1 sta morendo mi sa che abbiamo per a
tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fallite oggi siamo tornati su
woods your daddy ho deciso di introdurre
a pietro che mi ha chiesto di giocare un
gioco nuovo bello che merita anche ho
visto all'e3 di los enter che abbiamo
pagato 25 euro ai ho pagato per persona
di 10 10 euro per te l'ho preso per
tutti e due
apprezza le banane poligonali porca
vacca ciak custodi session tu puoi
customizzate il tuo bambino facendogli
indossare ma un cappello da professor
layton oppure un berretto da eminem lady
e call of duty cosa sta facendo
non lo so io sono solo il padre anch'io
ma siamo due padri chiudiamo una
famiglia del 2017
io a me piace vestirmi di prada da
buttare giù tutto che poi devo mettere a
posto io non aspetta
ci manca un bambino che dobbiamo
adottare un figlio guardami nuovo web
basta mettono nei cup ranzi di notte
guarda lo devo ordinare un figlio
coordiniamo figlio
finiamo non possiamo stare senza un po
dov'è il telefono squilla il telefono e
qui ti onda mite nip
questa è la cantina intel aveva un fiume
sia pronto pronto amazon vorremmo
ordinare un bambino grazie amazon prime
cielo in via non vanno una bara mimando
da voi no grazie quella la usiamo
stasera attesa ma cosa stai dicendo
ma se via vi dico a te di gare una sedia
tesoro tra l'altro che cosa possiamo
divertirci stasera ho paura
vieni qua
e allora questo dobbiamo testare abbiamo
così dietro di te la facciamo così io io
aggirati girati noi a strisce fatto nei
viali cugina del cuore l'amore
[Musica]
allora li facciamo ora sono il padre io
l'obiettivo tue suicida rovi gay come o
delle pil in mano pronto graziano che
servono per ingerire tele morire
ok io ti devo prendere devo farti stare
fermo dove cazzo val d'ala cimentare
lasciato andare noi sarà un modo
vomitare e cagare nel box zitto dall
ecuador 5 euro questo gioco pietro 5
euro ricordano ma perché bevi io bar e
poi chi lo dici a tua madre è quella
gioco che già lavora in autostrada a
ferma un attimo poi spiegare perché hai
un cappello da gentleman e appena tre
mesi
oggi la cametti ha trombato sei rimasto
così tutto bene pietro come perché sono
qui io sono a volte del di snob o che lo
vedevo suicidarmi questa è la mia
tattica devo suicidarmi tu sai
bye bye bye cucinava tecnici qualcosa
prendi la palla ma quale non apparirà la
barella missione del potentissimo dove
sei finito non era assolutamente in
cucina era per spiegarti ma dai
no no vieni qua papino chubut però la
mia vita brutta voglio uccidere vorrei
andare in prestito come come kg con
l'aex a dire basta
che bello il c bloc non isolando così
block papa non può giocare di prima le
poi va bene c'è una cosa buona qua cosa
è una pillola per morire
no no lo faccio non farlo lo faccio io
non parli ha la faccia non farlo
perché è il papa si diventa tornano sei
diventato il colli game of thrones
no no ciao papà dolore l'ho visto che
stava facendo terminare fisico viene
visto mangiando le batterie le basterà
mangiate completare il cervello a questo
mangiando le batterie che l'aveva presa
prepara avete tutto vedo tutto dove
scelte dove dove c'è no sì no te primis
perché non certo le batterie attraverso
stage o in proviamo non lo so vediamo se
siamo tutti dalla stessa stanza sua
squadra io sono il field figlio affetto
poi boys raidue che abbiamo gli paghiamo
in faccia nascondiamoci raccontiamoci
nascondiamoci ragazzi sono dei bastardi
non ci comprano mai neanche visco amiche
iniqui di ay ay a mio padre di dirgli in
faccia aiuto amiche io scappo marzo
perché guarda solo me è quello il primo
di pirlo fermato ore come li ha fermati
play con lucchetto le fermate piedi può
muoversi ma si può fare questa cosa a
quanto pare sì ma si fanno mangiare un
po di per lei e moriamo
no mi sono nascondere
mai mai mai mai capito fare porca vacca
mi chiudo nel freezer aiuto
no perché ti mando a chiudere acquistare
gli hanno preso a camerano tra ok ma non
venire da me no ho preso ma tu non sei
punto visto vuole provare a mangiare
l'immondizia maggior immondizia sono
ancora vivo per forum tv hanno dato la
medicina mi sapete avere comprato un po
di vita non voi noi siamo ai padri ok
andiamo di sopra
se si fanno del male da lì la mia oggi
ancora sono sotto però è 4 proprio
murray sono preso adesso lo è e rimane
un mio dovranno dei beni in testa non lo
so il muro muro di cose non facciamo
uscire ma anche la palla via via che qui
siamo in relazione svolta nokia tutto
blocca tutto vai vai tu amico io vorrei
darti una mano ma un altro bambino in
braccio come favori del bambino e uno
sta morendo dove mi sa che abbiamo
ciao cane tieni ti do questo bambino
mangia è a 506 gradi fahrenheit dice che
sta bene secondo me abbiamo dimenticato
la crema solare siamo di veroli si oggi
che c'è una cacca per terra cane vai a
cagare fuori quando abbiamo permettere a
questo di uccidersi non dobbiamo
permettere ok no quanto sta cagando il
cane è visto non è possibile via
wittgens almeno una partita l'ho vinta
basta basta basta shadow bene va bè
ragazzi questo è stato un musical
dediche abbiamo giocato anche con altre
persone abbiamo sì ha vinto che perso ma
non siamo bravi a fare i bambini in
realtà cioè io da piccolo ha tentato un
paio di volte era di mangiare la cacca
però sono delle storie che meglio hanno
raccontato gli spero che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi cosa avete sentite piaciuta
sull'argomento mi piace anche a vari
soci anche con benedizione
ciao sono iniziate che ci vediamo al
prossimo video ciao
[Musica]